please please here you're so transparent
I know why you're happy it's just
Republican publican hold the repeal of
Obamacare which means you will be able
to continue taking whatever drugs you're
on right now I know you're on drugs I
know I am but it's in this amazing I
mean for seven years this is all
Republicans live to do was repeal and
replace above it's all they talked about
it's all they voted on it's like it's
like the girl of your dreams finally
saying okay take me to bed and then you
get her there and
[Applause]
oh this looks bad for Trump because you
know how Putin feels about failure
[Applause]
that's right but know that this health
care thing went down because of the
freedom caucus that's the artist
formerly known as the Tea Party in
Congress Paul Ryan wrote a health care
bill that somehow covered fewer people
than just repealing Obamacare and
replace it with nothing and it still
wasn't good enough for the freedom
corporate caucus it's like if you wrote
a highway bill that made all the bridges
fall down and they said yeah but that
only kills drivers what about people at
home it is amazing what happened during
the week that the freedom caucus kept
taking away more things more health care
benefits to make it more attracted to
psychopaths in the last version they had
they had cut hospitalization doctor
visits maternity mental health lab tests
prescriptions emergency room visits
their version of health care was if you
like your doctor go [ __ ] yourself
and the freedom caucus still wouldn't go
along with it speaking for them
congressman Ted Yoho said yes that's all
on him that's his name he said this is
his quote he said it would still quote
leave a skeleton for the Affordable Care
Act and he will not stand any health
care plan that leaves America with the
skeleton he's a veterinarian I mean a
veterinarian which means his voters
think he was in the army
you know Republicans just have to admit
crafting legislation is just not your
thing calling into talk radio and
screaming about Mexicans yes posting
photo shops of Hillary with devil horns
yes naming buildings after Reagan of
course secret gay sex at highway rest
stop yes
legislation but you know there was so
much news this week this was only the
end of the week to healthcare thing but
besides Trump care
there was the Supreme Court hearings we
had there was the Russia news we're
burying the lead with that the Keystone
pipeline gonna okay today there was so
much news I'm going nuts trying to keep
up I've got the hearings on TV you got
the president on Twitter
I got Kellyanne on the microwave that
[Applause]
did you watch those hearings with the
nominee Neil Gorsuch for the Supreme
Court this is a guy Neil Gore said she
interprets the Constitution as the
framers intended when they wrote it 226
years ago which they say makes him an
originalist also Amish yeah that's what
the court needs another guy who says
what would slaveholders do but here's
our a real descent into the Banana
Republic
evanka you know Ivanka Trump is his
beautiful daughter wife Ivanka
[Applause]
this week she was given an office right
there in the West Wing and security
clearance to see classified information
she will not be paid a salary because
she's a woman
but in lieu of a page actually worked at
a deal where the nuclear codes will now
be carried in a purse from the Ivanko
collection so what you know what this is
how crazy [ __ ] up we are in this
country this is how crazy it's gotten
I'm glad she's there yes this has been
at a republic stuff but uh next to him
I'm glad Ivanka is there - it's like
when Janet Jackson used to visit the
Neverland red I'd talk to Mike